the Pope's recovery after a respiratory
infection today Pope Francis left the
hospital where he was being treated for
bronchitis the Vatican says the 86 year
old will be in Saint Peter's Square to
Mark the start of Holy Week tomorrow
Chris Love say is in Rome just outside
the walls of Vatican City this morning
good morning what started off as a rush
to the hospital for the 86 year old
pontiff has ended with a sigh of relief
and more than a few smiles
I'm still alive
as an emphatic good humored Pope told
journalists as he left Rome's Gemelli
Hospital on his way stopping to sign a
young boy's cast and embracing and
praying with a young couple who lost
their daughter the night before he was
taken here by ambulance for what turned
out to be bronchitis on Wednesday before
leaving he baptized a baby Miguel Angel
just a few weeks old the Vatican says
Francis also visited children in the
pediatric oncology department of the
hospital
tomorrow is Palm Sunday it was feared
he'd be celebrating from his hospital
bed and not in Saint Peter's Square
but thanks to this turnaround Francis
has now expected to preside over that
mass marking the beginning of Holy Week
which runs through Easter next weekend
this is not the Pope's First Health
scare fueling persistent rumors that
Francis now 86 might resign like his
predecessor Benedict did at 85 but
Francis is a very different Pope I have
never believed this Pope will resign I
have known him many years
and so I think unless there is a major
like a stroke which would paralyze him
in a way or interfere really with his
ability to govern I think he will die as
Pope
now Pope Francis will oversee Palm
Sunday celebrations here tomorrow and
he'll have the help of a cardinal for
altar duties leading up to Easter for
CBS Saturday morning Chris livesay Rome